à
[Musique]
toujours de ma thèse ma collègue de
bureau m'a préparé un magnifique gâteau
qui illustrait une bonne partie de mon
travail de thèse le gâteau en question
était peu usuelle il était un tiers
chocolat un tiers vanille et un tiers
red velvet et ça ça complique le partage
et oui parce que certains on préfère le
chocolat à la vanille au red velvet et
d'autres ont des préférences plus
farfelues comment partager un gâteau
pour que chacun soit content de sa part
alors je vois venir les plus matheux
parmi vous ce qu'on pourrait faire s'est
découpé le gâteau en parts non
mesurables puis recoller les morceaux de
sorte à obtenir le double de ce qu'il y
avait techniquement ça c'est
mathématiquement possible c'est ce qu'on
appelle le paradoxe de banhars tarski
dont l j vous apparaît dans cette vidéo
mais pour pouvoir y arriver il faut
utiliser l'axiome du foie dont j'ai
parlé dans cette vidéo est pour rappel
il s'agit de méthodes non constructive
donc a priori pas réalisable en pratique
a priori mais oublions ces bizarreries
de mathématiciens non constructifs
comment effectuer un partage juste d'un
gâteau hétérogène avec un nombre fini de
vrais coups de couteau est bien dans le
cas où il n'y a que deux invités il ya
une méthode en fait bien connu le jeu
coupe tu choisis
sardou plus
alors le jeu cook qui choisit est ce une
méthode de partage juste bien tout
dépend de ce que l'on entend par partage
juste peut on a vu dans la dernière
vidéo que c'était un concept loin d'être
trivial en particulier le jeu coupe tu
choisi n'est pas procéduralement
égalitaire ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que si c'était la loi alors le
cooper et le sélectionneur ne serait pas
à égalité devant la loi
et oui il y en a un qui a le devoir de
couper et l'autre celui de choisir et en
particulier le jeu coupe tu choisis ils
violent le premier article de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen mais d'un autre côté pourvu que
le découpeur prend le soin de découper
de parts qui selon lui ont la même
valeur
alors le partage obtenu sera
proportionnellement juste et sans
jalousie
en effet le découpeur aura forcément une
part qui selon lui vaut au moins la
moitié du gâteau entier et le
sélectionneur lui peut choisir entre ces
deux parts et donc la part qui choisit
représentera forcément selon lui au
moins la moitié du gâteau
du coup chacun a au moins la moitié du
gâteau pour lui et selon lui le partage
est donc proportionnellement juste est
aussi sans jalousie puisque le découpeur
à découper deux parts qui selon lui ont
la même valeur
du coup peu importe ce que l'autre
choisi il aimera forcément tout autant
sa part que celle de l'autre quant au
sélectionneur buy va choisir la part
qu'ils préfèrent du coup sa part aura
plus de valeur selon lui que votre part
bref au final bien que non égalitaire
devant la loi ni égalitaire en terme de
part la méthode je coupe tu choisis et
quand même proportionnellement juste et
sans jalousie et surtout est super
simple à appliquer c'est donc carrément
celle que je conseille en pratique alors
le jeu coupe tu choisis c'est bien mais
ça ne marche que quand il n'y a que deux
invitées que faire s'il y en a
maintenant 3 y at il encore une
procédure de découpe de gâteaux qui
puisse garantir un partage sans jalousie
et bien la réponse est oui il ya une
procédure dite de selfridge conway qui
garantit un partage sans jalousie pour
trois invités mais elle un petit peu
compliqué et quid du cas général avec l
invité eh bien il s'agit de l'un de ces
problèmes mathématiques qui a longtemps
été une question ouverte
et oui quand vous dire que partager un
gâteau ce n'est pas du gâteau mais ce
problème a finalement été résolu en
avril 2016 il y a un an par les
informaticiens aziz et mackenzie qui ont
enfin trouvé une procédure pour faire un
partage sans jalousie d'un gâteau entre
haine invités alors c'est absolument
génial ce qu'ils ont fait mais il ya
quand même un petit hic la procédure
d'asile et mackenzie peut requérir
jusqu'à n puissance n puissance n
puissance n puissance n puissance n
découpe du gâteau pour ceux qui se
rappellent de ma vidéo sur les nombres
archimica super géant l'algorithme
d'aziz & mckenzie requiert and flash
flash six étapes de découpe du gâteau or
ça pourrait n'égale deux c'est déjà plus
grand qu'un googleplex en particulier
c'est beaucoup plus grand que le nombre
d'atomes à l'intérieur du gâteau du coup
si vous utilisez algorithmes d'aziz
mckenzie pour seulement deux invités il
vous faudra déjà être capable de couper
les atomes en plusieurs morceaux voir
les particules élémentaires et comme
leurs noms l'indiquent priori les
particules élémentaires sont insécables
et puis même si les particules
élémentaires et est sécable le temps
qu'il faudrait pour arriver à bout de la
procédure d'asile et mackenzie serait
tellement grand que l'univers aura déjà
disparu d'ici là voir une fluctuations
quantiques aura déjà re créer d'autres
univers bref désolé pour ces petits
délires en pratique si la haine invité
une fois seulement une méthode beaucoup
plus simple et beaucoup plus expéditive
quitte à ne pas permettre un partage
sans jalousie et à se contenter d'un
partage proportionnellement juste est
justement une méthode relativement
expéditive qui va garantir néanmoins un
partage proportionnellement juste est la
méthode du couteau qui bouge
l'idée du couteau qui bouge c'est de
commencer avec le couteau à une
extrémité du gâteau puis de doucement le
déplacer de gauche à droite dès qu'un
invité dit stop il récupère ce qui est à
gauche du couteau et on continue ainsi
quand il ne reste plus qu'un seul invité
celui-ci récupère tout le restant du
gâteau si les individus sont honnêtes
alors le partage obtenu sera
proportionnellement juste mais il ne
sera pas forcément sans jalousie puisque
vous pourriez avoir choisi de sauter sur
la première page alors que la dernière
paraît quand même énorme
du coup il est possible que vous
préfériez la dernière par et vu que vous
avez déjà pris la 1ère vous
c'est la dernière alors le couteau qui
bouge ça le bon goût d'être expéditif
mais c'est peut-être un petit peu trop
expéditif en particulier les invités
doivent absolument être super réactif
pour ne pas dire stop trop tard pour un
partage toujours assez rapide
proportionnellement justin entre amis
uniquement moyennement impliqué dans le
partage je vous conseille davantage la
méthode dite du dernier réducteur les
méthodes du dernier réducteur consiste à
demander à chacun d'indiquer là où il
est prêt à couper pour récupérer la part
de gauche
si un invité est prêt à réduire la part
de gauche il prend un autre couteau et
le place là où il est prêt à couper
il devient alors le dernier réducteur à
la place du précédent mais peut se faire
remplacer par un invité qui seraient
prêts à encore réduire la part de gauche
quand plus personne n'est prêt à réduire
la part de gauche
le dernier réducteur récupère la part en
question et les autres invités répète la
procédure pour le restant du gâteau et
pour simplifier la vie de vous inviter
il est encore plus simple
la méthode des marqueurs dans la méthode
de themarker chaque invité mais n - un
marqueur numérotées de sorte que pour
chaque invité
s'ils ont découpé le gâteau au niveau de
ces marqueurs alors toutes les parts
aurait selon l'invité en question la
même valeur pour déterminer les parts de
chacun et on coupe au niveau du premier
marqueur que l'on rencontre la part à
gauche du couteau est alors donnée à
celui à qui le marqueur appartient on
retire tous les marqueurs de cet invité
et on retire tous les marqueurs avec le
numéro un
puis on recommence on prend le marqueur
le plus à gauche on coupe le gâteau à ce
niveau là donnent la part de gauche à
celui à qui le marqueur appartient on
retire tous ces autres marqueurs et tous
les marqueurs avec un numéro 2 et ainsi
de suite
là encore on obtient un partage
proportionnellement juste mais je vous
invite à imaginer un cas où le partage
ne sera pas sans jalousie et si on se
permettait maintenant d'introduire de
l'argent est bien avec de l'argent il
est possible de simplifier la procédure
de partage tout en garantissant à
partage proportionnellement juste et qui
aura même de bonnes chances d'être
strictement proportionnellement juste
dans le sens où tout le monde pourra
avoir strictement mieux
que dans un partage égalitaire la
méthode de partage qui va utiliser de
l'argent dont je parle est la méthode
dite des enchères caché avec
redistribution du surplus dans cette
procédure on va supposer que le gâteau
est composé de par insécables ça peut
être par exemple des bonbons qu'on n'a
pas le droit de couper ou détruits qui
n'ont pas sens à être coupés comme des
voitures ou les chambres affecté dans
une colocation
chaque invité écrit dans une lettre ce
qu'il est prêt à payer pour est
différente par mais sa lettre dans une
enveloppe recueille toutes les
enveloppes et on les ouvre en même temps
pour chaque bien on note tout les prix
que les différents invités sont prêts à
payer
puis on affecte chaque bien un invité
qui lui attribuent la plus grande valeur
mais de façon cruciale
les invités qui ont reçu trop de biens
vont devoir payer
et bien ce que chaque invité devra payer
sera ce qu'il a reçu en trop par rapport
à sa part proportionnellement juste par
exemple si alice reçoit la voiture et la
playstation mais pas le livre de
vulgarisation scientifique
alors alors à des biens d'une valeur de
700 euros selon elle
sur les 900 euros totaux que
représentent tous les biens selon elle
vu qu'il ya trois personnes
l'appart proportionnellement juste
calice considère devoir recevoir est
égal à 300 euros
elle aura donc obtenu selon elle 400
euros de trop par rapport à sa part
proportionnellement juste c'est ce
montant qu'elle devra payer de même bord
a reçu 500 euros sur les 600 euros de
biens à partager selon lui il aura donc
reçu 300 euros de trop par rapport à sa
part proportionnellement juste enfin
charlie a reçu 0 euros sur 300 euros de
biens selon lui du coup il a un déficit
de 100 euros par rapport à sa part
proportionnellement juste il devra donc
récupérer 100 euros au final il reste
alors quand même 600 euros dans la
cagnotte
et bien c'est 600 euros seront
redistribués de manière égalitaire entre
alice
si charlie on obtient alors un partage
socialement optimale dans le sens où
chaque gain est allé à celui qui lui
attribuent la plus grande valeur et ce
qui est assez fou c'est qu'on a réussi à
garantir cette optimale it et tout en
garantissant aussi que le partage sera
strictement proportionnellement juste et
ça ça fait beaucoup de très belles
propriétés la méthode et des enchères
cacher je vous la conseille vraiment en
pratique même si il faut faire gaffe au
fait qu'il n'ait pas incentive
compatibles les individus ont tout
intérêt à essayer de savoir ce que les
autres individus sont prêts à payer pour
les différents biens ou ainsi chercher à
acquérir un maximum de bien tout en
ayant à payer qu'un minimum d'argent et
à l'instar de plusieurs des méthodes que
l'on a vu aujourd'hui si les parties
prenantes départager c'est d'être
stratégique
alors certaines des bonnes propriétés
qui ont approuvé risquer de disparaître
bref vous l'aurez compris partager un
gâteau c'est vraiment pas du ghetto
d'adhérents s'est demandé si au juste
c'était juste et dominique leriche on
nous demande à mon il n'a pas de prénom
disait ça m'a fait pas mal rires ces
commentaires je vous avais aussi lui
demander si vous trouviez que la réponse
b était un partage juste et vous avez
été nombreux à répondre donc voilà la
réponse est venue 530 oui et 90 non
j'avais posé une fois la même question
quand je donnais un séminaire conférence
où il y avait que des étudiants des
thésards en économie et c'était un petit
peu plus partagée que ça mais le louis
avait tendance à l'emporter
je pense que sur ce genre d'occasions on
a tous envie de donner un avis mais ce
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est aussi
de voir ce que les gens pensent vraiment
dans tel partage puisque du cassiot non
démocratie qu'on peut vivre en
démocratie
ben c'est comme la vie du peuple et qui
est important alors je suis conscient
aussi que l'échantillon des gens qui
commentent mes vidéos series et est un
échantillon extrêmement biaisée de 16
est ce que je serais assez coeur de voir
si globalement les gens pensent que la
paix est vraiment
chose que juste ceci étant dit que le
peuple français soit d'accord avec la
justesse de ce partage non ça n'empêche
pas en tout cas les mathématiciens
d'essayer de réfléchir à ces questions
essayez de formaliser des notions qui
sont proches que ce qu'on pourra
entendre par notion de justice pour
pouvoir mieux comprendre les mécanismes
qu'ils étudient pour savoir lesquels
sont peuvent être considérés juste et
dans quelle mesure ils peuvent être
considérés juste ceci étant dit je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup à gagner aussi à
réfléchir sur des concepts plus
formalisé de ce qu'est la justesse pour
pouvoir mieux comprendre pourquoi est ce
qu'on pense ce qu'on pense qui est un
petit peu un des gros objectifs aussi de
cette série je précise me l'avez
remarqué j'ai quand même plusieurs
épisodes où je me suis demandé pourquoi
est ce que les gens pensent ce qu'ils
pensent et on reviendra d'ailleurs
surtout ça dans quelques épisodes qui
est intéressant avec ses formalisation
de la justesse c'est surtout que
indépendamment des opinions personnelles
des gens et même de nos propres opinions
personnelles
on est quand même capable grâce à cette
formalisation de ces concepts dénoncé
des douanes comme dire que le partage de
la réponse b et d'un partage 101
jalousie alors ça veut pas dire que
c'est forcément un partage juste parce
que juste et pas forcément synonyme
d'être sans jalousie mais j'aurais
tendance à essayer de vous encourager à
savoir ce que vous avez des débords
autre ami a essayé de formaliser ces
deux notions et essayer de séparer
autant que possible ce qui est du
ressort des avis personnel je pense que
c'est je ne pense que c'est plus de ce
qui peut être complètement formaliser et
être vrai indépendamment de toute
opinion personnelle comme parlant dire
que le arrêtons ce pays est un partage
sans jalousie ou le procès de sans
jalousie a été formalisée comme on l'a
fait dans l'épisode précédent
je pense que ce genre de réflexion fait
bien plus avancer les débats que lorsque
chacun donne son avis et qu'on n'arrive
pas à comprendre ce que l'autre entend
par le mot juste laurent nicollin ne
fait remarquer que en général il existe
plusieurs partage sans jalousie et or
dans le cas du partage de gâteau de la
vidéo précédente à la fois la réponse a
est la réponse b étaient des partages
sans jalousie est en effet laurent
nicolas même caractérisé tout un
ensemble de partage qui sont sans
jalousie et de la même façon mathieu
pascal fait remarquer que si on prend la
réponse b et qu'on retire la moitié du
gâteau à m alors on aura encore un
partage proportionnellement jeu
et sans jalousie sauf que bien sûr on
sent que ça te réponds ce jeu apb prime
est moins bonne que la réponse b
pourquoi et bien une façon mathématique
d'exprimer cela d'avoir le fait que la
réponse b est meilleur pour tout le
monde que la réponse des primes
en fait la réponse b et même optimale un
certain sens en particulier on ne peut
pas augmenter le guen être de quiconque
sans diminuer le bien-être d'un autre ça
ça correspond au concept de pareto
optimale it et a partagé par eto'o
optimale si on ne peut pas améliorer la
condition de quelqu'un sans détériorer
la condition de quelqu'un d'autre ou par
exemple le partage à n'est pas pareil
taux optimal puisqu'il est par eto'o
dominée par la réponse p est ce que dans
la poche mais tout le monde se porte
strictement mieux que dans la réponse a
est donc typiquement l'appareil taux
optimal t va être un concept qui va nous
permettre de discriminer de diarra
certains partagent sans jalousie sont
meilleurs que d'autres
mais là encore il peut exister plusieurs
partage par eto'o petit mot en général y
en existe même beaucoup et il peut même
exister plusieurs partage qui sont à la
fois barreto optimaux et sans jalousie
du coup dans ce cas quel est le partage
qu'il faut choisir dans l'idéal et ben
faut rajouter d'autres critères si on
veut continuer à discriminer différentes
partagent mais j'ai envie de dire oh que
si on a réussi à trouver un partage qui
est à la fois sans jalousie et par est
optimale je pense qu'on a fait du bon
boulot passe aux sciences avait anticipé
cette vidéo nous a demandé si on pouvait
considérer que la procédure de partage
était équitable bernière concept que
j'ai introduit dans cette vidéo qui est
l'égalité devant la loi
j'ai appelé à être procéduralement
égalitaire et on a vu notamment que le
jeu coupe tu choisis étaient pas
procéduralement égalitaire on peut le
rendre procéduralement égalitaire en
introduisant une randomisation c'est à
dire que avant de choisir qui coupent
qui choisit on tire une pièce et donc
avant que la pièce soit lancée on en
fait sur un pied d'égalité on est à
égalité devant la loi avant le lancer de
la pièce est en fait c'est un événement
aléatoire qui va casser cette symétrie
dit alors que la procédure et ex ante et
égalitaire
mes ex post c'est à dire après
l'événement aléatoire elle n'est plus
égalitaire et faire des partages qui
sont égalitaires ex ante et c'est
relativement facile
par exemple si je prends le gâteau avec
les trois souris et que je décide de le
donner à une seule personne par exemple
je dis qu'il n'a pas le droit de couper
ce gâteau peut le donner qu'à une seule
personne alors il ya un partage etc
santé égalitaire qui consiste à tirer au
hasard à la personne à qui on a donné ce
gâteau alors exposé il sera clairement
pas à égalité à et sera même pas sans
lui aussi puisque tout ne sera jaloux la
personne qui aura eu ce gâteau mais etc
santé avant l'événement aléatoire comme
tout le monde est sur un pied d'égalité
le partage peut être considéré etc santé
égalitaire en termes de parts de gâteau
donc ça peut paraître un petit peu tordu
ce que je raconte la mise en pratique
finalement laisser le hasard décider
c'est finalement pas une si mauvaise
façon d'effectuer un partage de quelque
chose qui peut pas être partagée
équitablement
enfin rémy chambord fait remarquer que
finalement quelque chose qui est
procéduralement égalitaire n'est pas
forcément souhaitable par exemple dans
le bus certaines places sont
prioritaires pour les personnes âgées et
personnes handicapées ou les femmes
enceintes
c'est bien qu'une certaine manière on
n'est pas à égalité devant la loi sur où
est ce qu'on a le droit de s'asseoir
dans le bus et dans le cas du bus il ya
un petit peu un consensus j'ai
l'impression en tout cas sur le fait que
c'est finalement une bonne chose que de
donner ces places prioritaires pour
certaines personnes et de faire du coût
de la discrimination
bref au final cet article 1 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen et en particulier ce principe
d'égalité risme procédurale et ben
finalement il n'est peut-être pas aussi
juste que ce qu'on pourrait croire
iwr espère que vous avez aimé cette
vidéo la prochaine fois on va parler de
méritocratie on va voir ce qui se passe
il ya des gens qui contribuent plus que
d'autres comment est-ce qu'on peut
redistribuer les biens qui ont été ainsi
produit de manière juste en tout cas en
un certain sens on va parler notamment
de la valeur de chapelets si vous avez
aimez cette vidéo pensez à la ligue et à
la commentaires de partager pense à vous
abonner pour le ton monte et futurs
épisodes merci aux types ou lordon et
j'espère que vous serez là
la prochaine fois tuvéri précise et
vérifiée ce geste est elle à ce format
[Musique]